This series now contains over a dozen
videos presenting the basic grammatical
features of Volcker Latin
and the romance languages.
Each video contained many
examples pronounced out loud,
but none of them address the
topic of pronunciation directly.
This video finally offers a rough sketch
of the pronunciation of vulgar Latin
and early romance with some notes on
how that pronunciation developed and
splintered as Proto Romance divided
into the modern romance languages.
Classical Latin valves had two values,
short and lung.
The name refers to how long the
val is held short versus bond.
Ah,
you can hear that long vowels are held
out longer in time in vulgar Latin.
The quality of a vowel became a major
difference between short and long vowels.
Some vowels sounded different even
if they weren't held longer, shorter,
long and short,
but short a long,
a short or long, Ooh, short,
long.
Ooh.
For example, Benny has a short
a well Belterra has a lung.
Hey,
notice how crucial the differences
in some prodo romance words.
The all in song is short,
but the o in Solo is long.
You can see that long mark
Macron above the long vowel.
Sometimes the short mark
is used above short valves,
but usually the valves aren't written
unmarked outside of educational materials.
The length of a is trivial. The
modern languages, most of the have a,
whether the val was a
longer short I in Latin,
but the historical length of
other vowels matters more often.
Sometimes what were once just long and
short versions of the same vowel or
spelled quite differently in the
modern romance languages. For example,
the verb bolted he can with a
short all comes out as Spanish way.
The French old Italian Walter
classical Latin used develop
vowel combinations I n hour,
which tended to but didn't always
merge with devours a and o.
Here's the word. Oh, cool. And
some of it's modern cognates,
and this is the word Christ Yona,
which was regularly pronounced
you on it in early romance.
Diphthongs also occur
for short a and short.
Oh damnit.
Spanish DNA.
Italian DNA. French. Yeah,
or both the Spanish way,
the French Romanian Wata.
Most consonants are pronounced
very much as they are in English,
but pay attention to these ones.
The stops written.
P T and c are an aspirated,
so they're pronounced without that
puff of air in or h sound that often
accompanies them in English.
So this word is pronounced battery,
not pottery.
This is to not to,
and this one is Gallo rather than Kelo
considered this an important note for
English speakers.
Okay.
The you in Wa and doesn't
fall silent and vulgar Latin.
So lingual and linguists
where aqua and aqua
or
Quando instead of French and Romanian
gunned late Latin speakers drop their H's.
So earlier Latin Hora became vulgar.
Latin aura.
The letter r was trilled
like aroma or threes.
V was pronounced,
not wa like it wasn't classical.
Latin Vino v later merges with B and
a few languages including Spanish,
which has been no
double consonants were pronounced long,
just as they still are.
An Italian flammer Ila,
the letters c and g represented stops.
Casa Kelo both with a cuff sound,
Gusto and gained both with a Gus sound
eventually see was soft and before Eni
originally palatalize to something
like Chia and eventually so sure.
Or some cello,
Spanish Filo,
Romanian change.
The same thing happens to
GE or GM before he and I,
which comes to sound like Joe
or Joe and later in Spanish,
Portuguese, Italian,
Jen Bay, Spanish Kane.
Uniquely Sardinian doesn't do this.
So g and c stay close to their original
and Gus sounds before he and I in
Sardinian cello,
French CN,
Sicilian shell, but Sardinian, Caillou,
Kya and gear.
Our examples of palatalization vulgar
Latin consonance turn Palatal by
pronouncing a short, yeah, after the
consonant and before another val.
This why sound is written
with an I or sometimes the j,
so and or no is palatalized
in the word bowel.
New l gets palatalized in Maryetta,
t is palatalized in Gracia.
This little y sound has a lasting
impact on later romance words.
For example,
that palatalized t in Grotzia doesn't
stay a t thanks to palatalization that
Tiaa eventually becomes
a sung in French glass,
sir, in Italian Grotzia
and in Spanish. Yeah.
Palatal consonants don't
always get treated the same.
Either take the Prodo romance word venue,
which has the Palatal [inaudible]
sound in Portuguese and Galician.
This comes out as venue and Benu,
but Italian and Spanish
have vengo and Bingo,
which no longer have palatal
sounds, romance, consonance,
where sometimes soften between valves and
this was routinely the case in western
romance languages like
French, Spanish, Katelyn,
oxygen and Portuguese.
This process called [inaudible] explains
why the final t in Tato becomes voiced.
D and Portuguese [inaudible] a the sound
in Spanish gone tallow and disappears
entirely and Caribbean
Spanish going to allow.
This is also how he's single.
S comes to sound like zoom between two
vowels in many romance languages aside
from Spanish and Romanian,
Casa, Italian, Gaza,
Portuguese causa,
but Romanian Casa,
vulgar,
Latin and early romance syllables often
contain a vowel or a consonant plus
avowal better equaled a single
consonant may close the syllable factor.
Yeah,
consonant clusters were also found like
plug in [inaudible] or the script in
script.
Most words had a prominent louder
syllable and this stressed syllable was
typically the second to last one,
like in [inaudible] or Casa.
Sometimes it was the third to last
syllable, like in Pearl spittle or Betty,
the other syllables where unstressed,
unstressed syllables where sometimes cut
out. This happened at the end of words,
particularly in Romanian, French, Occitan,
Katelyn and Romance Burrow
Sparrow becomes French post spare,
which lost its final syllable
and solid becomes Spanish son.
Without that final e,
sometimes the middle syllable
was cut out better equal.
Lou was shortened to Betty clue
and later Spanish belly grow.
This has been but a rough sketch of
vulgar Latin ed romance pronunciation.
It's meant to help you understand the
pronunciation of words throughout the rest
of this grammar of romance,
but it's also a springboard for learning
more about the pronunciation of Latin,
of individual romance languages,
and of the historical sound changes
that took place between them. Validity,
and thanks for learning with
me.